welcome back the foreign secretary
dominic rabbs announced sanctions
against
four chinese officials and a
construction company
for human rights violations against
uyghur muslims in
china's xinjiang province it comes after
the eu the u.s
and canada announced similar measures
the first imposed against beijing since
tiananmen square
in 1989. i'm joined now by minister yang
guo
guang uh de faire at the chinese embassy
in
london thank you for joining us
um are you really surprised by these
sanctions you've had
two successive u.s administrations occur
accusing you of genocidal acts in
xinjiang so
are you really surprised by sanctions
well thank you mark for having me
i'm not surprised by the
decision of the british government but i
feel
disappointed and i strongly opposed
to this move because this is a totally
wrong decision first there's no
so-called genocide or forced labor
or mass sterilization or other things we
call it the
lies of the century the acquisition
against us
in xinjiang is totally groundless and
not based on facts
secondly sanction especially unilateral
sanctions
violates international law and the basic
norms governing international relations
so we're opposed to these kind of
sanctions
third sanctions will be useless to
china you know it will only reunite
the chinese people and the basic
response i heard is that
the officials feel honored
to be sanctioned by
by the the u.s uh eu or other countries
because they have successfully
safeguard national sovereignty
securities okay let me ask you a
question then what do you call
then the forcing of men women and
children
into concentration camps because that's
what
the u.s secretary of state says
he says that you're re-educating
incarcerated uyghurs into the ideology
of the communist party and that speaks
he said and i quote
to an effort to commit genocide
there is no such a thing of genocide
genocide
is more accurate for the united states
who uh in two or three centuries ago
centuries ago who have killed the
indians
this is not the thing happened in
xinjiang
i apologize i don't really want to go
quite as far back as that answer these
questions then are you forcing weaker
women
to be sterilized of course not
china is a takes a family planning
policy
and we have favorite policy for weaker
minority groups
uh well you know we have to take the
policy
nationwide but for weaker minority
groups
they can give birth to three children
it's much more favorable to compare with
other ethnic groups
and also the accusations against the
chinese government
are totally groundless cases are not the
true facts okay are you separating
uighur children
from their families
no that's not the case we set up the
education and training center especially
for those
who have conducted minor offenses
of radical extremism
and who might be brainwashed by the
extremists and we uh
we take measures in preventative
measures
uh in preventing terrorist attacks
and this policy have proved to be
effective and we have safeguarded their
rights
including the rights to reunite with
their families but human rights
human rights groups uh are saying that
these are concentration camps that's
what the
americans are saying is what the uk is
these are called lies of the century
is what the eu is saying and it's also
what uh
39 countries who have signed a statement
at the un is saying
the pictures you shown your show just
now
actually is a transition of prisoners
from one prison to another it's nothing
to do with
education and training center you know
you have to take preventative measures
and there are no abuses you see
no abuses everybody is in good condition
but we have to take preventative
measures because they are
dangerous prisoners and on the other
hand
in the human rights council meeting just
now there are 70 there are 64 countries
supporting china's policy in xinjiang
including many of the arab states they
have visited xinjiang to see
with their own eyes so we can judge
which is wrong which is
true well human rights groups say that
this is they are heading for forced
labor
and they also say they're heading for
re-education camps
to re-educate uyghurs in the ideology of
the communist party
no we don't need forced labor actually
xinjiang's cotton industry is highly
mechanized
we don't need human labor nowadays yeah
and also with a few positions they are
highly paid
so people compete with each other to get
such a job
why don't they need to be forced and for
the center
education training center they are
taught
with chinese language the chinese law
and necessary skills to improve their
lives okay
quick word on hong kong the plan was one
country two systems
isn't the truth that it's now one
country one
one system it's still one country
two systems but you know there's a
precondition of one country
in the past especially after the turmoil
in
2019 one country has been seriously
affected so we have to strengthen the
other side
uh of one country meanwhile two systems
it's uh accurately safeguarded it was
supposed to
continue sorry to interrupt it was
supposed to be a partly election
elected parliament until at least 2047
so why it have you wiped out any serious
democratic
representation and why are you jailing
opposition politicians if it's really
one country two systems
no nobody is present or
accused because just of what they said
but because of what they are doing
they have done seriously
crimes affecting national unity
calling for hong kong independence is
that's not a tolerable
and uh with we will safeguard this
democracy
in hong kong and what we are doing is
also to
ensure that one country's two systems
will work well
work long and for the majority of the
benefits of people in hong kong but it's
effective it is a rubber stamp
parliament now isn't it
no i no the parliament will be widely
represented by
all walks of life they can still express
their different
opinions uh their speech rights
are safeguarded but you know there's a
precondition not to be
calling for hong kong independence or
something like that
our integrity it must be observed okay
appreciate your time thank you for
coming on thank you